bien tout le monde a pris
place mes chers collègues nous
accueillons aujourd'hui Monsieur Hervé
Berville secrétaire d'État chargé de la
mer monsieur le ministre merci d'avoir
accepté cette audition qui maintenant
devient régulière dans dans notre
commission nous l'avions sollicité il y
a tout juste un mois au moment où les
pêcheurs réunis à Nice pour leurs
assises annuelles clamer leur inquiétude
n'hésitant pas à dénoncer une tr du
gouvernement après la fin annoncée de
l'aide au carburant au 15 octobre
dernier devait en effet cesser les aides
à la trésorerie de 20 centimes par litre
Alain CADC nous l'a rappelé la semaine
dernière consenti aux pêcheurs pour les
aider à faire face à la flambé du prix
du gazol après l'invasion russe de
l'Ukraine la filière aliotique voyait
dans l'interruption de ses aides recondu
depuis 18 mois à plusieurs reprises pour
un montant total de 75 millions d'euros
un cataclyme qui aurait précipité sa fin
il est vrai que la flotte française 3è
de l'Union européenne derrière celle de
l'Espagne et du Danemark apparaît très
fragile é prouvé par une succession de
crise le covid brexit impact de la
guerre en Ukraine le nombre de navires a
diminué de plus d'un/art en 20 ans
nombreux d'entre eux sont vieillissants
sans parler des marins dont près de la
moitié partiront à la retraite d'ici 5
ans 5 à 10 ans et dont la situation
sociale est tendue en effet la rmun tion
des marins se réduit à mesure que le
prix du gazol augmente vous expliquiez
alors ne plus pouvoir prolonger ces
aides au gazol en raison de l'expiration
du régime européen qui les autorisé et
vous annonciez un plan de transition
énergétique des navires de pêche avec à
court terme une réduction de 13 centimes
par litre financé par Total énergie et
censé compenser la fin de la remise de
20 centimes ce plan n'a pas apaisé les
pêcheurs qui vous ont défillé en
appelant au président de la République
vous avez depuis fait marche arrière et
annoncé il y a 2 semaines que l'aide
serait finalement prolongée jusqu'au 4
décembre pourquoi ce revirement
pouvez-vous nous assurer que l'aide au
gazol sera prolongé aussi longtemps que
durera la guerre en Ukraine et que les
prix du gazol euh et que les prix du
gazol demeurent bien sûr
élevés vous avez en parallèle pris
l'engagement de poursuivre la
mobilisation au niveau européen afin que
l'encadrement temporaire de la crise de
la Commission européenne qui autorise
jusqu'à fin décembre le versement de
cette aide soit prolongé en 2024 et
associé à un relèvement des plafonds
vous avez rencontré avant le commissaire
européen à Luxembourg où vous
participiez à un conseil pêche avez-vous
obtenu de sa part les garanties à ce
sujet nous restons inquiets la pêche
vous le savez c'est tout une filière
trois hommes à terre pour un homme en
mer c'est une filière d'avenir pour
l'économie pour l'environnement et pour
la souveraineté alimentaire de la France
alors que nous importons déjà plus de 75
% du poisson consommé dans notre pays
elle façonne nos paysages nos cultures
l'identité des populations côtières
pourtant
entre l'absolutisme de la Commission
européenne autour des air marines
protégées les projets d'éolien offshore
les menaces sur les
côas 2026 les préoccupations
s'accumulent nous sommes aussi
préoccupés de savoir que la réserve
d'ajustement au brexit pour laquelle
nous avions bataillé en soutien à nos
pêcheurs est loin d'être consommé dans
un rapport de juin dernier la Cour des
comptes dénoncait l'organisation
défaillante et la faible mobilisation
des administrations française pour
consommer ces fonds nous attendons de
votre part un bilan du bénéfice que la
pêche aura pu en tirer d'ici la date
limite qui est au 31 décembre 2023 car
il ne serait pas acceptable que cette
enveloppe soit largement redéployée vers
d'autres objectifs comme on nous laisser
entendre vous comprendrez bien dans ce
contexte que nous tenions à vous
entendre aujourd'hui sur sur l'ensemble
de ces points et plus généralement sur
votre vision de la filière pêche et de
la stratégie pour assurer son avenir je
vous cède la parole monsieur le ministre
après nous aurons un temps de
questions-réponsse avec nos collègues
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénatrices et
et sénateurs en effet ça devient une
belle tradition ou en tout cas un
rendez-vous régulier qui permet au-delà
des questions urgentes et des questions
qui anime si ce n'est qui agite parfois
vos territoires nos territoires permet
aussi de réfléchir sur le long terme
parce que je crois que ce que nous
devons porter ensemble ce sont des
politiques de long terme pour nos
pêcheurs pour nos territoires et
notamment pour les plus jeunes pour
assurer à la fois la souverainé
alimentaire de notre pays et en même
temps la protection de la biodiversité
la protection de la ressource donc moi
je reviendrai je 10 minutes si je
m'abuse monsieur le Président je vais
essayer de de faire le plus court
possible pour laisser la place à toutes
les questions parce que je crois que ce
qui est le plus intéressant mais
peut-être revenir sur trois sujets un
d'abord les questions d'urgence
notamment la question de l' carburant de
ce que nous avons engagé aussi depuis la
dernière fois qu'on s'est vu sur des
réformes structurelles et ce qu'on est
en train de mener avec la filière avec
les territoires pour faire en sorte de
pas se retrouver et moi je souhaite
vraiment qu'on arrête d'avoir cette
gestion des pêches qui passe d'un plan
de sortie de flotte à des a de carburant
parce que ce n'est pas souhaitable et ce
n'est pas durable sur le long terme et
donc il faut qu'on arrive à avoir une
gestion de la pêche qui soit une gestion
pérenne et qui s'appuie notamment aussi
sur des mécanismes de solidarité au sein
de la filière comme il en existe dans
d'autres filières et puis je reviendrai
sur les quelques échéances de long terme
notamment la préparation de l'accord
avec la Grande-Bretagne ou encore la
nécessité dans le cadre des élections
européennes qui arrivent de et vous
l'avez dit monsieur le Président de
faire évoluer la politique commune des
pêches pour faire en sorte et bien de
garantir notre souveraineté alimentaire
quand on sait qu'on importe 80 % des
produits de la mer d'abord sur la
première question la question des Z
carburants d'abord vous dire Monsieur le
Président que ce n'était pas un
revirement ce n'est pas un revirement
c'est un exercice et je crois que ce que
nous devons à nos pêcheurs quand je suis
allé aux Assises de la pêche c'est un
exercice de vérité de transparence et de
lucidité je leur ai indiqué qu'au stade
à l'heure où je leur parlais il n'était
pas possible de prolonger les carburant
non pas parce que la France ne le
souhaitait pas mais parce que le cadre
européen ne le permettait pas et donc
pourquoi je l'ai indiqué parce qu'il
fallait se préparer pour justement avoir
des
mécanismes alternatifs qui permettent de
pas se retrouver dans une impasse mais
dès le mois d'août dès le mois d'août
mes services le ministère de de la mer
et puis bien évidemment le gouvernement
français avait fait une demande de
prolongation voyant que le le coût du
carburant par rapport à ce qu'il était 2
mois avant avait augmenté on était passé
de 50 centimes à à peu près quasiment 95
centimes mais moi je le fais depuis le
début comme on l'a fait sur les armes
marines protégé comme on le fait sur le
plan d'accompagnement individuel je dis
les choses en vérité en transparence et
en vérité en transparence c'est que je
ne pouvais pas dire en septembre que
c'était garanti qu'il y allait avoir une
prolongation des carburant et donc il
fallait qu'on se prépare et ça a
fonctionné ça a permis notamment d'avoir
des mécanismes de solidarité avec un
engagement volontaire de la part de
total pour et j'y reviendrai tout à
l'heure pour avoir une diminution à la
pompe de 13 centimes ça a permis
d'accélérer le travail sur le contrat
stratégique de filière et donc je crois
que cet exercice et vous êtes les
premiers aussi porteurs et dépositaires
de ça il faut dire les choses aux
pêcheurs en toute transparence pour pas
les laisser dans une situation d'impasse
et pour pas se retrouver euh au pied du
mur et donc sur la question de l'aide
carburant je l'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire à l'excellent sénateur cadek la
semaine dernière l'aide apporté par la
France et par le gouvernement français
n'a ni précédent ni équivalent dans
l'Union européenne c'est 75 millions
d'euros c'est grâce et bien à l'action
de la France et à la demande de la
première ministre et du président de la
République que nous avons prolongé par
quatre fois par quatre fois l' de
carburant que le seuil qui était de
30000 € est passé à 330000 € 30000
330000 € c'est plus que dans d'autres
secteurs et puis sur surtout nous avons
fait en sorte que on ne laisse personne
de côté notamment les les pêcheurs
artisanaux et faire en sorte et bien que
partout dans nos territoires ils
puissent sortir en mer tout ça sajoute
bien évidemment à ce que depuis le début
de la crise nous mettons également dans
la filière c'est plus de 230 millions
d'euros que ce soit sur des arrêts
temporaires sur la sole ou encore sur le
plan de gestion westm donc ça c'était la
première urgence de carburant et donc
bien évidemment j'ai j'ai le indiqué il
y a de cela de semaines nous avons
prolongé les carburant jusqu'au 4
décembre donc ce qui permettra de
laisser personne dans l'impasse au 15
octobre et nous avons dorg déà fait la
demande à la Commission européenne de
pouvoir prolonger jusque en en en 2024
car comme vous l'avez dit les prix
restent élevés mais tout ça encore une
fois en toute transparence en lucidité
je peux pas vous garantir que aDVITAM
etnam il y aura et d'ailleurs la
discussion que nous devons avoir c'est
de faire en sorte de ne pas se retrouver
dans une situation où nous dépendons
totalement d'une décision de la
Commission européenne et qu'il faut
avoir des mécanismes de couverture du
carburant car toutes les grandes crises
de la pêche sont des crises du carburant
et donc il faut avoir des mécanismes qui
permettent de se couvrir et de pas être
aussi vulnérable sachant en plus que
nous ne produisons pas de pétrole et
donc on est très dépendant de la de la
volatilité des marchés extérieurs la
deuxième urgence vous le savez c'était
le plan d'accompagnement individuel ou
plan de sortie de flotte j'avais pris
devant vous trois engagements un ce plan
d'accompagnement individuel il il devait
maintenir les équilibres géographiques
en gros il fallait pas qu'il y ait un
nombre conséquent de navire détruit dans
un territoire qui fait que il se
retrouve dans une situation où la
viabilité du secteur de la pêche se
retrouve fondamentalement touchée de
nous avions souhaité nous avons pris
l'engagement que 100 % des licences
brexit soi rendu ce qui est la première
fois dans l'histoire des plan de sortie
de flotte c'estàdire que là nous avons
la certitude que toutes les licences
brexit qui ét attaché à des navires qui
ont été détruits ont été rendus ce qui
permet de maintenir nos capacités à
produire c'est un engagement que j'avais
pris il a été tenu et puis le troisième
engagement c'était celui de préserver
aussi l'aval de la filière et donc grâce
au combat que nous avons mené je voulais
vraiment remercier aussi les services du
ministère parce que ça fait plus de 8
mois qu'il travaill sur le sujet auprès
de la commission nous avons réussi aussi
à avoir un plan d'accompagnement de
notamment des marayilleurs nous avons
réhaussé le plafond qui était de 30000
en le portant à 200000 € et donc nous
allons mettre en œuvre un plan de
soutien des marilleeurs et je sais que
c'est très important dans vos territoire
qui permettra d'accompagner à hauteur de
12 millions d'euros ce secteur qui est
vital puisque s'il n'y a pas de
marilleeur c'est très compliqué ensuite
d'avoir et bien ces produits très bons
et magnifiques transformés dans nos
étales et donc la dernière urgence qui
est devant nous donc la première c'est
aide carburant la deuxième c'était la
l'accompagnement de ce plan de sortie de
flotte la troisème urgence qui est
devant nous c'est celle bien évidemment
de la négociation tac et cota de la fin
d'année alors là aussi je vais le dire
en toute transparence et en toute vérité
elle va être très très très compliquée
très compliquée à part peut-être sur le
la la partie manche où ce sera un peu
moins simple un peu pardon un peu plus
simple toutes les autres espèces tous
les autres secteurs géographiques sont
dans une situation où c'est une baisse
significative voire
drastique la raison étant que selon euh
le le conseil scientifique il y a une
baisse du stock qui ne veut pas dire que
c'est dû euh aux pêcheurs principalement
ça peut être aussi d'autres facteurs
mais euh forc de constater qu'il y a une
baisse de la ressource et donc ça va
avoir un impact sur nos pêcherie euh et
sur notre secteur de manière très forte
comme l'année dernière bien évidemment
je vais me battre pour à la fois
défendre la souveraineté alimentaire de
la France et défendre tous nos
territoires parce qu'il s'agit pas de
favoriser euh Paul au détriment euh de
de Jacques et donc on va le faire avec
euh trois euh approches ou en tout cas
trois principes qui me guident et qui
nous ont guidé l'année dernière qui nous
on permis là aussi d'avoir un résultat
plutôt positif l'année dernière c'est un
se baser bien évidemment sur la science
et reconnaître les efforts qui ont été
réalisés par nos pêcheurs
de adapter et bien tout ça au territoire
parce que la réalité de la Méditerranée
n'est pas exactement la même que celle
du golf de Gascogne et trois prendre en
compte un des piliers essentiels de la
politique commune des pêches qui est la
viabilité économique de nos entreprises
et et on doit bien prendre en compte le
fait que si jamais nous sommes dans
situation où il y a une grande partie de
nos entreprises de pese qui s'effondrent
c'est notre capacité et bien à maintenir
de la souveraineté alimentaire sur le
long terme qui s'en trouve affecté
sachant en plus que dans le même temps
nous avons pas mis en place des closes
miroirs au niveau européen qui nous
empêcherait d'importer des produits qui
n'ont pas les mêmes standards
environnementaux et sociaux donc ce
serait une forme de de folie à la fois
commercial environnemental et social et
donc j'ai rencontré la semaine dernière
pour cette semaine pardon mon homologue
belge néerlandais aussi pour sur ces
trois piliers on part de la science on
prend en compte la viabilité économique
des entreprises comme l'un des piliers
fondamentale de la PCP et on adapte ce
que l'on fait au territoire c'est ce qui
nous permettra je le crois en tout cas
c'est ce que nous allons porter et bien
d'avoir un résultat qui soit peut-être
moins négatif que ce qui est envisagé à
l'heure actuelle et vous pouvez compter
sur moi bien évidemment pour me battre
pour tous nos territoires tout ça
renforce ma conviction on l'a déjà
partagé je sais qu'un certain nombre de
vous le partage ici la conviction qu'il
faut aller vers la pluri annualité des
quotas ce n'est pas possible de se
retrouver dans une situation où vous
avez des stocks qui l'année dernière
diminuer de 10 % cette année sont à 0ro
l'année dernière augmenté de 20 % cette
année sont à - 30 % ça donne aucune
visibilité à nos pêcheurs ça empêche
d'avoir des investissements sur le long
terme et ça décourage je crois une
gestion durable de ces pêches et donc
nous le faisons sur le ton et on voit
que ça fonctionne puisque nous avions au
Conseil européen aussi euh une une
discussion sur la gestion de cette
espèce et donc à la demande de la France
et de l'Espagne l'année dernière au
Conseil européen nous avons demandé à un
premier travail sur la gestion
plurriannuelle d'un certain nombre de
stocks et nous avons identifié pour
cette année la pli la langoustine et la
sol et donc moi ce que j'ai demandé
c'est d'accélérer parce que et je le
vois dans l'dc maritime dans lequel je
vais nos jeunes nous demandent vraiment
d'aller dans cette gestion
plurriannuelle ce qui permettra d'avoir
et bien des entreprises qui soient plus
solides et surtout d'avoir aussi des
rapports scientifiques qui évoluent
beaucoup moins d'une année à une autre
voilà c'était les trois urgences que je
voulais évoquer avec vous mais au-delà
de tout ça comme je vous l'ai dit notre
responsabilité ma responsabilité c'est
bien évidemment de construire des
réponses de long terme des réformes
structurelles de la filière qui est
demandé par les pêcheurs qui est
demandés par les territoires et aussi
qui qui sont demandés par nos
concitoyens et donc le le premier
élément que nous avons porté depuis le
salon de l'agriculture c'est le contrat
stratégique de filière qui vise au fond
à mettre autour de la table les trois
maillons de la chaîne les pêcheurs les
premiers acheteurs c'estàdire les criers
les marilleurs et la transformation pour
assurer plus de solidarité entre ces
acteurs là parce que quand l'un tombe
l'autre va être en fragilité et donc on
a besoin vraiment comme de d'autres
secteurs de renforcer cette solidarité
et puis surtout d'être en capacité sur
des sujets très précis et je remercie
vraiment Frédéric touliou de France
filière pèche d'avoir vraiment porté
avec le président Olivier nezette ce
sujet là surtout aussi depuis de mois il
y a des sujets très concrets sur le
économique de la filière avec
l'instauration d'un observatoire sur la
réflexion sur l'augmentation de la
première mise en marché décrié ou encore
le renforcement de l'attractivité des
métil de la filière bref tout ça sont
des sujets alors certes qui font pas
l'ouverture du 20h mais qui sont
fondamentaux pour pouvoir assurer la
souveraineté de notre pays et assurer
l'équilibre aussi économique sur T nos
territoire et donc l'ambition c'est
d'avoir ce contrat stratégique de
filière qui est en fait un contrat entre
les acteurs de la filière qui soit prêt
pour le salon de l'agriculture de
février au-delà de ce contrat straté de
filière moi j'ai souhaiter que les
acteurs privés aussi travaillent sur des
mécanismes de solidarité et c'est la
raison pour laquelle total a pris un
engagement volontaire à travers à la
fois un verdissement de son carburant et
une rour à la pompe de 13 centimes de
pouvoir s'engager avec la filière pêche
c'est bon pour la transition énergétique
c'est bon pour le pouvoir d'achat de nos
pêcheurs et ça permet là aussi d'avoir
des liens plus forts entre des acteurs
qui sont intrinsaquement liés
c'est-à-dire que pour les pêcheurs la
question du carburant jusqu'à
aujourd'hui on essaie d'en sortir le
plus rapidement possible elle est clé et
pour bien évidemment un acteur comme
Total qui est un acteur français et je
crois qu'il a un minimum de patriotisme
il ne peut pas considérer qu'il peut
laisser tomber comme ça des acteurs
comme les pêcheurs et donc nous avons
avancé en tout cas les acteurs privés
ont avancé et l'idée c'est d'avoir avec
le PLF de cette année cet amendement qui
permettra d'avoir ces 13 centimes à la
pompe dès le 1er janvier de cette année
et en parallèle de ça un autre acteur
privé important c'est engagé là aussi
dans ces mécanismes de solidarité je
veux bien sûr parler de CMA CGM qui a
mise en œuvre un fond de décarbonation
du secteur de la pêche de 20 millions
d'euros pour l'année prochaine qui
permet et on a déjà des remontées de
premiers projets qui permet de financer
de la remotorisation qui permet de
financer la réduction et bien de la
consommation de carburant qui permet de
financer aussi des techniques de pêche
qui sont moins énergivores 20 millions
d'euros dès le 1er janvier de cette
année en lien avec la BPI qui permettra
là aussi de montrer que les acteurs
privé entre eux peuvent trouver des
mécanismes qui permettent que ne ce soi
pas simplement des financements publics
qui soi utilisés et puis le le troisème
point de ce que l'on doit faire sur la
les réformes structurelles je vous
disais donc il y avait le contrattif de
filières il y a les mécanismes de
solidalité le troisième c'est les
engagements que j'ai pris notamment aux
Assises de la pêche sur des
simplifications qui sont attendues
depuis longtemps par nos pêcheurs et je
veux en citer trois parce qu'elles sont
importantes et notamment les élus de de
Méditerranée me l'ont évoqué très
souvent c'est la question par exemple de
la médecine d'aptitude des gens de mer
qui est une médecine qui était compliqué
à pouvoir avoir et donc nous allons
lancer une expérimentation dans lesé Ros
et dans le morbillant pour que la
médecine de ville puisse et bien passer
les différents examens ce qui permettra
à de nombreux pêcheurs qui parfois
attendent un rendez-vous avec la
médecine des gens de mer et bien de
pouvoir embarquer plus rapidement là
aussi ça permet de réduire les tensions
sur le marché du travail C attendu
depuis très très longtemps ça paraît
anodin mais pour le pêcheur qui attend
son rendez-vous c'est quelque chose
d'important et vous le connaissez vous
sur la question de la fracture médicale
ensuite un autre point qui est attendu
depuis très longtemps c'était
l'alignement de la réglementation
européenne en passant de
0,2 de 0,2 de 0 à 2°gr à 0 à 4°gr pour
les températures des criers et des
entreprises là aussi ça paraît un Odin
mais en fait c'est un alignement sur le
niveau européen ce qui permet d'avoir
aussi une compétitivité de no criers qui
soit aligné avec les standards européens
et et puis le troisème point parce que
c'est important aussi pour nos régions
c'est l'alignement le renforcement entre
les lycées et les entreprises de pêche
les lycées maritimes pour améliorer les
conditions de stage et consolider
l'insertion sur le long terme de nos
jeunes en lien bien évidemment avec la
réforme du lycée professionnel que vous
connaissez ça permettra là aussi de
faire découvrir des métiers peut-être
plus tôt et montrer la diversité des
métiers de la mer à nos jeunes et
d'avoir aussi bien évidemment par bassin
des débouchés économiques et des
débouchés d'emploi pour nos jeunes et je
terminerai par là monsieur le président
par le la troisème grande partie qui est
celle des prochaines échéances et qui
sont des échéances importantes et que
nous nous allons bien évidemment
construire ensemble d'abord c'est ce que
j'ai annoncé aux assistes de la pêche
nous devons absolument réduire notre
dépendance aux énergies fossiles un pour
le climat de pour la viabilité
économique de nos entreprises et donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
annoncé un plan de transition
énergétique de la flotte que nous devons
préparer dès maintenant segment de
flotte par segment de flotte territoire
par territoire et qui sera appuyé sur
les financements issus de de latex
éolienne en mer c'est-à-dire 450
millions d'euros sur les 10 prochaines
années c'est un choix que le
gouvernement a fait de dédier ces 400 en
tout cas dédié 450 millions d'euros
issus de la tax éolienne pour la
transition énergétique de la flotte
parce que si nous voulons avoir une
flotte qui soit adaptée aux enjeux du
21e siècle qui soit adapté aussi aux
besoins et aux demandes de nos jeunes
d'avoir des navires plus confortables
plus silencieux plus économes en
carburant voire zéro émission nous
devons l'engager maintenant alors c'est
un travail de long terme c'est un
travail qui sera fastidieux mais on on
doit l'engager maintenant parce que
notre responsabilité c'est pas de se
retrouver dans 10 ans avec encore des
crises de l'énergie des crises du
pétrole que nous devrons gérer au coup
par cou ça c'est le premier point et
c'est un point qui est important nous
sommes le seul pays à s'être engager
pour l'instant dans une telle démarche
et nous le faisons avec une flotte qui
est très diverse parce que de
Méditerranée en passant par la aussi nos
navires qui se trouvent au large de
l'océan Indien ou encore dans le
Pacifique à ceux qui se retrouvent au
large des côtes anglaises ce sont des
secteurs très différents avec parfois
une incapacité dans le secteur maritime
en tout cas dans le secteur secteur de
la construction des navires d'avoir des
passages à l'échelle comme c'est
possible dans la voiture ou comme ça
possible dans l'avion parce qu'il y a
quasiment autant de navires qu'il y a de
de construction de bateau et donc c'est
pour ça que il faut des moyens
financiers importants et qu'il faut un
accompagnement mais il faut faire
maintenant pour qu'on arrive très vite
d'ici notamment nos atteintes
d'objectifs climatiques de 2050 nous
puissions être au rendez-vous le
deuxième point qui qu'on travaille dès
maintenant mais qui est aussi un combat
de long terme c'est l'attention
particulière et que je porte à nos outr
mèes
une grande partie de notre souveraineté
de notre autonomie stratégique passe par
ces territoire ultramarin qui compose
bien évidemment l'écrasante majorité de
notre surface maritime nous avons ob
tenu une belle avancée auprès de la
Commission européenne puisque nous avons
eu une augmentation du DI minimis pour
moderniser pour accompagner les navires
de moins de 12 m ce qui est attendu
depuis très longtemps c'est largement
insuffisant je le reconnais monsieur le
Président mais un un pas a été mis dans
la porte et et clairement ça nous engage
dans une dynamique de reconnaissance que
nous avons besoin de moderniser nos
navires de pêche dans les territoires
ultramarins surtout que il y a des
navires d'autres pays qui sont parfois
financés par le dead public au
développement européenne qui viennent
concurrencer voire faire de la pêche
illégale dans nos eau donc nos
compatriotes ultramarins ne le
comprennent pas à juste titre et nous
devons absolument leur donner les
capacités de moderniser leur navir pour
notamment avoir une souveraineté
alimentaire qui est bien normale donc la
deuxième étape c'est le nous attendons
le rapport de de de la commission qui
nous dira si les segments que nous avons
identifiés sont à l'équilibre et si nous
pouvons avoir l'autorisation là et bien
de financer d'accélérer ce financement
nous sommes positifs dans le sens où
nous avons donné toutes les données et
en tout cas on a fait tout ce que nous
avions à faire et maintenant c'est à la
Commission de jouer et de nous dire
quelle sera la décision et enfin sur les
territoires ultramarins ce qui est
important pour moi c'est vraiment d'axer
aussi sur la question de la formation et
sur la la question de la création et
bien de de de de de formation de CAP de
lycée qui permettent et bien d'avoir un
développement de la finilière maritime
je l'ai fait en Guyane avec la création
d'un CAP pour la première fois il aura
un cap maritime qui permettra d'avoir
des formations pas simplement pêcheurs
mais aussi mécanicien dans le secteur
naval dans le secteur maritime nous
l'avons fait aussi à la réunion avec la
création d'un lycée maritime qui est
l'évolution d'une maritimisation du
lycée professionnel de la Réunion et je
viens vraiment rendre hommage à Huget
Bellot qui s'est vraiment battu sur ce
sujet depuis des années et donc nous
l'accompagnons aussi et puis c'est je me
rendrai le mois prochain en Polynésie où
avec le président mu brotherson nous
allons lancer des travaux pour là aussi
des formations maritimes pour la pêche
mais aussi pour des formations maritimes
qui sont liés à la construction de navir
qui sont liés à la réparation de navire
ce qui permettra là aussi de renforcer
la souveraineté alimentaire et la
souveraineté économique de pays vous
voyez j'ai une attention particulière et
c'est un sujet de long terme pour faire
en sorte que dans nos territoires
ultramarin nous avons des formations
maritimes et je terminerai mesdames et
messieurs par une échéance importante
qui est celle bien évidemment de la
préparation du de l'accord de commerce
et de coopération avec le Royaume-Uni
j'ai mandaté un député Bertrand Brix
pour anticiper préparer cet accord je je
pense que nous pourrons avoir ce travail
parallèle aussi au Sénat et je suis prêt
à en discuter en tout cas l'œil et
l'expertise du Sénat sera importante sur
sur ce sujet-l mais il faut absolument
et moi j'ai demandé à mes équipes d'être
en ordre de bataille pour que nous
soyons prêts pour 2026 parce que ça
guidera beaucoup de notre capacité à
pouvoir garantir l'accès aux EAU à à nos
pêcheurs dans les prochaines années et
puis je terminerai par là c'est la
nécessaire évolution de la politique
commune des pêches nous avons une
opportunité c'est qu'il y a des
élections donc il faut absolument faire
monter ce sujet de de la politique
maritime intégrée la question de la
préservation de la biodiversité la
question de la préservation de l'habitat
marin et la question bien évidemment
d'avoir aussi une approche économique
commerciale de la pêche notamment avec
un sujet pour moi qui est fondamental et
j'ai eu l'occasion d'envoyer un courrier
aux deux commissaires j'attends encore
la réponse sur la question des mesures
miroires on ne peut pas continuer à
demander un certain nombre d'efforts
certes légitime à nos pêcheurs si si je
prends l'exemple sur la question de la
crevette nous continuons à porter des
crevettes qui viennent d'Équateur je
n'ai rien contre l'équateur mais qui
n'ont pas du tout les mêmes standards et
donc ça on l'a fait dans d'autres
secteurs il faut que nous le fassions
pour le secteur de la pêche ce sera un
gage de confiance et je crois de respect
vis-à-vis de nos pêcheurs et puis
surtout ce sera un gage de qualité dans
nos assiettes et notamment dans la
restauration collective de nos enfants
ou dans d'autres secteurs publics donc
voilà Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs ce que je voulais dire c'est
que il y a des urg sur l' carburant nous
sommes au côté des pêcheurs il y a
encore beaucoup de choses à faire et
nous continuons à nous battre notamment
à l'Union européenne pour porter un
certain nombre de priorités comme cell
des tac et cota qui vont arriver mais
comme celle aussi de la modernisation
des règles pour les territoires
ultramarins et avec cette vision qui est
une vision à la fois de protection de la
biodiversité et de souveraineté
économique je n'ai aucun doute sur le
fait que nous aurons encore des pêcheurs
des haute France en Bretagne en passant
par nos territoire ultramarin dans les
prochaines années je vous
remercie merci monsieur le ministre de
de vos réponses et et je vais laisser la
parole à à mes collègues tout de suite
mais avant je je voudrais revenir sur un
point que j'ai évoqué dans dans dans
dans ce texte dans en préambule qui est
la réserve d'ajustement du brexit on n'a
pas vu euh au cadre financier
pluri-annuel au dernier cadre financier
pluri-annuel les fonds pour la pêche
vraiment augmenté en tout cas ils sont
restés relativement stables à Euro
constant et euh on pourrait considérer
que cette réserve d'ajustement du brexit
qui nous amené à peu près 800 millions
d'euros pour lesquels à la fois le
gouvernement mais aussi les
parlementaires s'étaient batttu dans
leur dans dans leur discours ne soit pas
aujourd'hui un fond complètement utilisé
et dédié à la pêche moi j'entends dire
plein de choses euh maintenant je
puisque vous disiez que c'était aussi le
moment de vérité de s'exprimer euh euh
clairement sur le sujet je voudrais
savoir combien allons-nous rendre à
l'Union européenne alors probablement
que ce seront des fonds qui seront
rendus à la France ous d'autres sous
d'autres aspects mais en tout cas je je
je regrette vraiment que ces 800
millions qui étaient dédiés à la pêche
ne le Soi pas intégralement en tout cas
c'est à peu près 800 millions euh ne
soit pas intégralement utilisé euh euh
pour euh destination de la destination
de la filière en tout cas voilà oui oui
et puis après je passe ah pardon parce
que je me semble que j'ai une question
gouvernement sur le sujet mais sur ça je
vais être très très clair ENF je je je
ne sais pas d'où ça sort tout ça là
peut-être que ce sont les idées du de de
fin d'année qui qui germe un peu par d's
mais sur le sujet c'est très clair un
nous avions une réserve d'ajustement
brexit qui est lié et ce sont les règles
européennes qui nous oblige parce que
sinon on va faire rembourser à des
pêcheurs dans quelques années des choses
qu'ils auront obtenu euh cette réser
d'agion brexit elle était strictement
pour des sujets qui étaient liés aux
conséquences du brexit en ce qui
concerne la France certes le rapport de
la Cour des comptes dit qu'il y a eu
dans certains ministères je ne vais pas
en citer des utilisations qui étaient
parfois pas à la hauteur des attentes
mais en ce qui concerne le ministère de
la mer monsieur le Président elle a été
très bien utilisée elle a été très bien
utilisée le rapport de la Cour des
comptes le dit et donc nous avons
utilisé cette réserves d'ajajustement
brexit pour le PAI et pour d'autres
éléments qui sont liés directement aux
conséquences du brexit mais vous
comprenez bien que je ne pouvais pas et
je ne peut pas utiliser une réserve
d'achement brexit sur un sujet de
carburant puisque ça ne répondrait pas
du tout aux lignes directrices ah mais
parce que c'est ce que j'entends un peu
donc non mais je sais bien vous le dites
pas mais j'entends d'autres je lis
d'autres choses aussi donc réserve
d'ement au brexit elle a été elle a été
utilisée en ce qui concerne le ministère
de la mer et la Cour des comptes le
reconnaît juste pour la raison pour
laquelle avait été mise en œuvre ensuite
il y a eu mais ça date de de février de
cette année il y a eu étant donné qu'il
y avait des fonds qui qui qui étaient
encore disponibles qui ne p pouvait plus
être utilisé dans le cadre des
conséquences du brexit parce que elle
s'était dissipée nous avons convenu et
ça a été indiqué notamment au
collectivité locale et ça a été organisé
concerté au niveau européen d'utiliser
ces financements là qui étaient encore
disponibl mais qui sont pas retournés
dans une caisse à l'Union européenne
pour notamment la transition énergétique
et écologique et donc si je ne m'abuse
je crois que c'est 400 millions d'euros
qui sont de du gouvernement français
mais c'est la même chose dans d'autres
pays européens c'est à peu près
équivalent qui ont été remontés mais
pour être utilisé dans le territoire
national pour des sujets de transition
énergétique quand on voit notre la
volatilité des prix et notre dépendance
un certain nombre d'énergie on comprend
que c'était une bonne utilisation de ces
fonds là sachant que notamment nous en
France nous avions moins besoin certain
nombre de sujet sur le breit donc ça ça
a été acté en février et surtout les
fonds devaient être utilisé avant juin
avant juin donc cette question c'était
très clair la rabe elle s'est terminé en
juin donc voyz voyez bien que pour l'
carburant même maintenant c'était pas du
tout le cas et donc pour répondre très
clairement il n'y a pas de cagnotte
magique quelque part de l'arabe le
ministère de la mer les a très bien
utilisé pour les pêcheurs notamment dans
le casadre du PI en faisant attention à
ne pas déstabiliser la filière et les
financements qui étaient pour la France
ont été utilisés pour la France dans le
casadre de la transition énergétique
oui monsieur le ministre mais néanmoins
vous n'enlèverez pas le désordre créé
dans mon esprit puisque vous nous
expliquez
qu'effectivement les crédits utilisés
pour le break enfin qui était dédié au
brexit ne peuvent pas l're ne pourrai
pas le l'ettre autrement que pour ça et
finalement on les redispatche sur autre
chose si les 400 millions les redispat
sur autre chose que c'est c'est pas dans
le dans on a remonté ces crédits là en
effet pour des sujets qui sont plus liés
au breésit mais en fait là ce que vous
parce que ce qui était demandé ce qui
était une demande de dire on peut
utiliser ces crédits là maintenant pour
les de carburant c'était pas vous qui le
dites mais c'est ce que j'ai entendu
mais en fait ce que je voulais vous dire
c'est que depuis février nousous avons
déjà fait l'arbitrage et ça a été
partagé à tout le monde et en plus
c'était une date limite d'utilisation en
juin et donc bien évidemment quand nous
avons fait la la maquette budgétaire ne
ne sachant pas évaluer quel sera
l'impact du brexit notamment vis-à-vis
de la pêche personne ne savait si on
allait être dans la nécessité de
détruire 20 navires ou 100 navires donc
on avait une enveloppe qui était plus
importante moi j'ai limité au maximum
vous le savez bien donc on avait une
enveloppe plus importante ce qui a été
convenu dès le début c'est que une fois
que nous avons terminé la maquette
budgétaire et évaluer les besoins en
février avec un décaissement en juin
l'argent remonterit mais serait
réutilisé pour autre chose mais il
viendrait pas être utilisé 6 mois après
donc c'est c'est assez clair sur à la
fois le calendrier et sur
l'utilisation euh et je rappelle aussi
que notre commission avait souhaité que
la réserve d'ajustement du brexit ne
serve pas unique ne serve pas du tout
justement au plan de sortie de flotte
parce que c'était pour nous un non sens
économique ça a été décidé autrement
mais je rappelle que notre commission je
rappelle que notre commission avait
avait oui je suis d'accord mais moi je
vous rappelez ce que j'ai dit quand je
suis arrivé sur le le le plan de de
sortie de flotte mais enfin pour le coup
là c'est pour c'est s'il y a bien des
financements qui sont pertinents c'est
bien ceci merci Monsieur le Ministre on
va attaquer les questions alors je vais
demander à à chaque commissaire d'être
clair et rapide concis dans sa question
pour que le ministre réponde on les
prend par trois parce que je vous
rappelle qu'à 3h on a les questions
d'actualité donc il faut qu'on ait
quittter la salle à 3h-5 on commence par
Giselle jourdda puis NAD JAV qui se
prépare merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre merci de votre
exposé je voudrais moi mettre le focus
ce que vous avez d'ailleurs évoqué et
répondu d'ailleurs pour partie c'est sur
la question de la pêche ultramarine
parce qu'aujourd'hui on a une
mobilisation au niveau de la Commission
européenne qui se propose d'augmenter de
30000 à 40000 € sur sur 3 ans l'aide
pour donc la rénovation de la flotte de
de pêche pour nos pêcheurs ultramarins
c'est tant de ça de ce qu'on peut donc
estimer et de ce qu'on peut donc
attendre et prévoir je pense que nos
départements ultramarins mérite un
soutien plus accru et surtout vous avez
parlé monsieur le ministre de point de
vigilance nous comptons sur vous pour
que cette vigilance soit accrue et pour
qu'il ne soient pas les parents pauvres
de la modernisation de cette pêche
ultrar qui est une des ressources pH de
nos départements don ultramarin je fais
pas donc NAD jab alin Cadec se prépare
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je voudrais revenir sur un
texte qu'on a voté au mois de mai 2023
sur le dumping social et la proposition
de loi de Didier leac j'aimerais savoir
où en sont les décrets d'application et
s'ils seront bien pris effectivement
pour la fin de l'année savoir également
si il y a des suites qui seront données
au niveau européen et notamment parce
que c le toit elle a un cadre global et
qui est beaucoup plus protecteur pour
des professionnels impactés et puis je
voudrais revenir sur ce dont vous avez
parlé tout à l'heure sur les quotas
étant Nord fininistérienne euh il y a
énormément de petits pêcheurs de lieu et
il y a de lieu jaunes notamment et il y
a quelques temps dans le journal Le
Télégramme il était dit que bientôt la
pêche au lieu serait probablement
interdite je vous remercie Alain Cadec
et puis monsieur le ministre je vous
répondraz sur les tro monsieur le
ministre quel souffle vous avez un
souffle extraordinaire je vous félicite
parce que vous avez parlé pendant PRS 12
15 minutes là sans vous arrêter je me
suis dit c'est pas possible il va pas
tenir comme ça quand
même il a tenu il a tenu félicitation
vous nous avez expliqué que bah tout
allait bien tout était quasiment
réglé vous avez quasiment réponse à tout
avant d'avoir les questions
d'ailleurs alors moi je dirais bon je me
permets avec HERV quand même mais bon
attention ne pas être bardé de trop de
certitude monsieur le ministre parce que
certain nombre de choses que vous nous
avez dit tout de suite qui sont
d'ailleurs des pour l'essentiel des
vérités ne ne ne malheureusement ne ne
règle pas les problèmes ne règle pas les
problèmes de la pêche vous avez évoquer
un certain nombre de choses je dirais
toutes les choses concernant la pêche
vous avez balayé euh euh et en disant
par exemple je partage votre avis il
faut qu'on arrive rapidement au plan
pluriannuel vous y travaillez par
rapport au quotas qu'on a actuellement
et ça ça fait des années qu'on en parle
au niveau des institutions
européennes et donc vous avez aussi
évoqué l'aide l'aide qui serait
consentie par Total
ou la richourne de 13 centimes par litre
de de de Gasol mais vous avez oublié de
préciser que vous l'avez dit mais
rapidement que c'était dans dans dans la
mesure où où les les navires utilisaient
des biocarburants mais pour qu'il pour
qu'ils utilisent des biocarburant encore
faut-il qu'ils en aient c'est-à-dire
qu'ils puissent en recevoir or vous le
savez très bien il y a très peu de ports
qui sont aujourd'hui équipés en
biocarburant sur le littoral français ma
connaissance il y en a trois ou quatre
donc c'est une mesure qui est
intéressante mais qui est impossible à
mettre en œuvre euh à l'échelle de du
pays donc expliquez-moi comment vous
allez faire par ailleurs vous parlez de
choses que je partage c'est-à-dire la
transition énergétique la remotorisation
des navires euh mais tout ça monsieur le
ministre vous le savez ce sont des
mesures à moyen voire à long terme pour
ne pas dire très long terme et vous
l'avez dit vous-même nous sommes dans
l'urgence et aujourd'hui dans l'urgence
on n pas de de de réponse on n pas de
solution même si vous nous avez fait un
exposé remarquable de 12 ou ou 13
minutes donc encore une fois
euh moi je je je suis inquiet j'ai peur
pour la pêche française vous le
savez j'ai peur je suis pas le seul j'ai
peur pour la pérenité de la pêche
française de la filière hein pas
seulement la pêche he toute la la
transformation et donc tout ça ne me me
rassure pas par ailleurs vous l'avez
évoqué rapidement vous avez dit que vous
aviez donné la responsabilité à un
collègue député d'ailleurs moi je suis
très inquiet sur le la fin de la période
de transition qui arrive en 2026 parce
que là les les nos amis britannique
entre encore je dis amis entre
guillemets nous feront sans doute pas de
cadeau et donc il faut absolument qu'on
qu'on se prépare à cette cette cette
situation et c'est à vous monsieur le
ministre avec vos vos vos collègues
espagnols néerlandais Belg allemands qui
sont il y en a d'autres mais qui sont
concernés directement par cette la fin
de cette période de transition de faire
pression sur le Royaume-Uni pour que on
est une fin période de transition qui
soit acceptable bon je je pourrais
encore vous en dire plein comme ça mais
enfin en tous les cas j'arrête moi je
j'ai pas autant de souffle que vous
monsieur le ministre voilà bon ce n'est
pas du favoritisme mais comme monsieur
cadek est président du groupe pêche je
l'ai laissé parler un petit peu plus
longtemps à vous monsieur le ministre
ancien
président commission pêche Parlement
européen c'est normal non madame Jourda
sur la la question de la pêche
ultramarine enfin moi je partage tout ce
que vous avez dit c'est une discussion
qui est très compliquée parce que il
faut faire arriver enfin il faut faire
comprendre en tout cas expliciter la
diversité de nos territoires ultramarins
ce qui aussi sont des similitude sur la
véuceté d'un certain nombre de navires
on s'est battu sur le sujet ça a été
très long et là c'est pas beaucoup de
certitude he ce que j'ai dit je l'ai dit
au début c'est un petit pas en passe de
30000 à 40000 très bien mais on est loin
d'être au bout du de de de la discussion
on a commencé ça en 2018 et je voulais
rendre hommage également à la ministre
Annie Girardin qui s'est battu
euh comme personne pour pouvoir faire
avancer ce dossier mais moi compte sur
moi pour notamment en fait l'enjeu qui
est devant nous c'est celui des lignes
directrices et faire bouger ces lignes
directrices je l'ai rappelé chaque fois
que je vois le commissaire c'estàdire
une fois par mois je lui parle de ça il
va se rendre à la réunion parce qu'on a
poussé aussi pour cette ce déplacement
donc nous espérons qu'il aura des bonnes
nouvelles dans sa besace mais donc vous
voyez c'est un processus qui est parfois
comment dire fastidieux mais en tout cas
qu'on continue a poussé et je voulais
vraiment vous remercier et puis aussi
les députés européens et tous les élus
locaux parce que je crois qu'on on est
uni sur cette questionl et il va falloir
qu'on le fasse encore plus fort après
madame avet sur la question de la loi
dumping social
euh nous sommes toutes les consultations
ont été faites les parlementaires et je
voulais vraiment vous remercier aussi
puisque vous avez été rapporteur pour
cette magnifique lo qui a une belle
avancée d'ailleurs on va porter le sujet
maintenant au niveau européen aussi
grâce à vous euh les décrets vont être
présentés au Conseil d'État dans les
tous prochains jours avec une une
application une mise en œuvre pour le
premier semestre de 2024 et donc les
parlementaires que vous êtes qui étaient
impliqué sur ce sujet ont été consultés
on a eu des retours de de la part de de
de vos équipes et de tout le monde donc
ça avance bien il y a quelques petits
points sur lequels il faut qu'on qu'on
ajuste mais en tout cas c'est une loi
qui s'est fait dans un temps record il y
a un an on parlait d'un risque là aussi
juste un enfondrement de britannisphéris
maintenant nous avons une loi qui en
miroir des salalles des Britanniques
avec des décication qui vont arriver qui
vont nous permettre et bien de défendre
le modèle social français et d'éviter
d'avoir cette spirale euh infernale et
euh ce dumping social dans nos eau et en
ce qui concerne le lieu euh là bon c'est
une situation qui est très compliquée
euh on va se battre on va essayer de
donner les meilleurs arguments j'ai pas
de certitude sur l'issue euh mais en
tout cas vous pouvez compter sur moi
comme sur d'autres sujets pour à la fois
mettre en avant la nécessité et de
maintenir des activités de pêche là où
c'est possible et en même temps de
préserver la ressource parce que si on
préserve pas la ressource il y aura plus
de pêcheurs dans 20 ans donc j'ai bien
pris ce sujet notamment quand je suis
venu dans le Finistère vous voir et je
vous remercie aussi de votre
mobilisation monsieur cadek monsieur le
Président vous l'avez dit vous me dites
beaucoup de certitude non j'ai j'ai
commencé d'ailleurs mon propos sur
l'urgence en disant que nous sommes dans
une situation très compliqué et je ne
sais pas comment on va ressortir sur les
TAC et quota je crois que c'est loin
d'être des certitudes non mais voilà
donc je dis les choses en vérité il y a
des choses sur lequel je suis sûr et
surtout il y a un bilan et des choses
sur lequelles on doit progresser avancer
je reconnais pleinement que donné
simplement un mois et demi de visibilité
à nos pêcheurs pour carburant c'est pas
optimal mais c'est ce qu'on obtient au
niveau européen vous connaissez le
système européen et donc on se bat au
maximum pour avoir le plus de visibilité
mais quand je peux quelque chose je le
dis et et je le fais quand je ne peux
pas et quand je suis pas sûr comme sur
les tacacota je vous dis que ça va être
très compliqué je le dis aussi en ce qui
concerne la question de Total en fait
pour bien comprendre le sujet c'est que
on va pas commencer tout de suite par du
physique il y a des stations je crois
que c'est l'Orient et puis Brest on peut
avoir du biocarburant il y en a trois
mais les autres en fait ce sera du
monétaire c'est c'est c'est des titres
c'est des titres qui s'échangent donc ce
sera sur la globalité du carburant de
Total qu'on dira il y a une accoration
de 7 10 à 15 % de biocarburant il y a
aucun problème technique on a fait une
réunion la semaine dernière avec tous
les distributeurs de carburant avec les
pêcheurs avec les constructeurs on en a
fait une il y a de semaines également on
a fait un questionnaire pour tous les
pêcheurs aussi pour bien répondre aux
enjeux est-ce que ça va avoir des effets
sur l'efficacité sur la rentabilité de
mon moteur et cetera tout ça c'est bien
calibré cadré et donc au début on
commencera pas par du biocarburant
physique ce sera des titres ce sera du
monétaire ce qui se fait dans d'autres
secteurs et qui permet d'accélérer et
puis je je je terminerai monsieur le le
président parce que vous m' dit sur la
question des urgences on répond pas à
tout je reconnais je je je sais bien
qu'il y a des inquiétudes mais notre
rôle aussi et votre rôle enfin si je
reprends les articles de journaux quand
vous-même vous étiez président la
commission des pêches je peux vous dire
que on disait souvent que la filière
allait mourir ben grâce à votre action
grâce à l'action des différents
gouvernements on a réussi à la maintenir
à la rendre viable ça n'a pas empêché
qu'on a plus de 30 % des flops qui ont
disparu grâce à l'action de la
ministreing Gerardin on a réussi à se
battre sur les cotas on a réussi à se
battre sur la modation des des flottes
donc chaque nouvelle génération ou
chaque nouveau ministre il a des
nouveaux combats on est toujours dans
l'urgange parce que on est une politique
qui dépend de l'Union européenne c'est
une politique ine une politique qui
dépend beaucoup et bien de la
disponibilité de la ressource une
politique qui dépend beaucoup aussi de
la demande de nos concitoyens et donc du
pouvoir d'achat et donc les paramètres
qui étaient vrais
20 mois sont un peu différents et donc
sur ça moi j'ai n de certitude non pas
parce que je penserai avoir réponse à
tout mais simplement sur des engagements
que j'ai pris sur les AR marines protégé
sur l'enjeu de l' carburant sur les
licences vous rappelez vous me disiez il
faut que 100 % des licences soit rendu
après le P elles ont été toutes rendu et
donc ça il faut le dire si moi je le dis
pas personne ne le dira c'estutre pas
vous monsieur présidentad qui le dira et
donc c'est important de
l'avir je sais
bien
bien merci alors Karine Daniel puis se
prépare Mathilde Olivier pour la 2e
série monsieur le ministre vous l'avez
dit la lisibilité qui est offerte sur
les questions de de carburant et et de
court terme
et globalement et structurellement on
observe une augmentation des des coûts
pour pour les pêcheurs et je relis ça je
relais cette inquiétude concernant la
question de de l'installation et de
l'arrivée de de nouveaux entrants dans
cette filière qui inquiète beaucoup dans
les ports pour que se renouvelle
finalement cette main- d'œuvre et et
cette filière donc moi mon interrogation
c'est est-ce qu'il y a des actions
spécifiques au-delà de la formation que
vous avez évoqué pour renforcer l'aide à
l'installation sur la question des
investissement dans une période aussi où
les taux d'intérêt augmentent et euh
donc sur les les investissements qui
permettent aussi de se projeter de
projeter les jeunes génération dans une
économie on va dire moins carbonée par
rapport à ce que vous avez dit tout à
l'heure sur la question de la
décarbonation de la flotte mais aussi
des ports et ça c'est une question qui
qui est importante pour nous sur le plan
européen vous l'avez dit on est toujours
dans dans un équilibre où on
doit à la fois avancer les enjeux
environnementaux de de
renouvellement évidemment de de la
ressource alitique et les enjeux
économiques de de court terme et de
moyen terme mais là je pense que y
compris les filières sont plus am mênes
et est prête à
accepter des mesures de court terme pour
préserver l'activité à moyen et long
terme et la position de la France sera
très regardée de de ce point de vue et
évidemment espérons que ce ce sera un
enjeu qui sera aussi discuté dans le
cadre des élections européennes sur ce
volet de de contrôle des pêches moi
j'avais une question concernant les
investissement à opérer par par les
pêcheurs et par les flottes sur
justement le contrôle euh de des volumes
et de la nature de de la pêche opérée on
sait que va y avoir des obligations
d'équipement en outil numérique en outil
de contrôle donc qu'est-ce qu'il est
prévu sur ce volet pour accompagner les
acteurs de de la filière et les pêcheurs
spécifiquement Mathilde Olivier et
Didier Marie qui se
prépare bonjour monsieur le ministre euh
alors je voulais revenir sur l'article
17 de la politique commune de la pêche
donc qui impose aux état Membre lors de
l'attribution des possibilités de pêche
d'utiliser des critères transparents et
objectifs y compris les critères à
caractère euh environnemental social
économique donc les quotas de pêche sont
décidés au niveau européen puis répartis
aux état en par les États-membres dans
des proportions stables d'année en année
mais en France les organisations de prod
c'est c'est les organisations de
producteurs qui
rassemblent qui rassemble qui joue un
rôle important et la règle de base est
celle de l'IST historicité donc si un
navire avait 2 % des quotas de merlu il
y a 15 ans il continuera d'avoir 2 % des
côas de merlu en 2023 2024 donc ça crée
un système qui est quand même très figé
et il est assez facile pour des
armateurs de concentrer une part de plus
en plus importante des quotas en
rachetant des bateaux alors que
prévoyez-vous pour intégrer des critères
sociauxenvironnementaux dans cette
attribution des quotas parmi les
critères de répartition de ces quotas de
pêche et puis il y a aussi un euh un
vadmum cum de la Commission européenne
qui doit être rédigée est-ce que vous
participez au niveau français euh à la
rédaction de ce VAD meum et quelle est
la la position du Gouvernement sur ces
aspectsl notamment encore une fois sur
ces critères environnementaux et sociaux
euh ça a aussi un impact à la fois sur
les jeunes pêcheurs dont on parlait sur
l'installation de ces jeunes pêcheurs et
PU sur le développement durable de la
pêche euh en favorisant en essayant de
favoriser une petite pêche côtière et
une répartition plus équitable des
quotas euh donc voilà si vous pouvez
revenir là-dessus et deuxièmement sur la
préservation de la biodiversité euh et
sur notamment la question des dauphins
communs échoués sur les sur les côtes
euh on sait qu'il y a eu de nombreuses
alertes des scientifiques ces dernières
années de la société civile de l'Union
européenne euh et que la situation de
des populations de dauphins et
actuellement dramatique le Conseil
d'État a rappelé le gouvernement à ses
obligations il y a quelques mois
maintenant où en êtes-vous dans la
protection de ces de ces dauphins vous
avez il y avait un projet d'arrêté mais
qui qui était quand même assez éloigné
des injonctions du Conseil d'État et et
je vais m'arrêter là parce que ça fait
déjà c'était c'était les prérogative de
la benjamine du
sénatsieur monsieur Didier Marie
merci président euh monsieur le ministre
merci de des informations que vous nous
avez donné euh je voudrais revenir sur
deux sujets qui ont été en partie
évoqués par Karine Daniel et et et un
autre qui ne l'a pas encore
été le le 17 octobre dernier le
Parlement européen
a adopté à un accord après 5 années de
négociation avec la Commission et les
États-membres euh sur le renfor
forcement des contrôles et et et des
sanctions sur les prises et sur les
rejets illégaux en en mer en vue de de
protéger la la réserve aliotique eu un
certain nombre d'éléments sont déclinés
dans cet accord notamment la nécessité
de l'enregistrement électronique des
prises à venir ce qui aura ce qui vient
d'être évoqué des conséquences
financières importantes pour nos
pêcheurs je voudrais
cependant avant d'en arriver là
connaître la position que le
gouvernement va défendre au prochain
Conseil européen sur cette accord si il
le valide ou non et et ensuite bien
évidemment s'il est validé quelles
mesures seront défendues pour
accompagner le financement de cette
numérisation au regard des difficultés
que rencontre déjà notre flotte
artisanale la la deuxième
difficulté liée à la situation que l'on
connaît aujourd'hui c'est que euh la
Chine pour ne pas la nommer euh continue
de développer sa présence dans les mers
du monde euh pêche à peu près
aujourd'hui 15 % des prises totales
alors qu'elle était à 5 % il y a moins
de 10 ans
et pratique pour bon nombre de ces
bateaux de la pêche illégale or dans
l'accord qui a été trouvé il y a une
volonté de contrôle de l'ensemble des
des prises euh comment comptez-vous euh
mieux contrôler euh cette flotte dont on
ne connaît d'ailleurs pas exactement le
nombre de bateaux euh comment éviter des
importation de poisson qui auraiit été
pêché illégalement euh en Europe ou en
France euh et donc quelles sont les
dispositions que la France souhaite
défendre à l'échelle du Conseil européen
à l'égard de cette pêche en grande
partie illégale monsieur le
ministre merci beaucoup pour toutes ces
questions passionnantes comme cell
d'avant bien évidemment alors madame
Daniel euh sur la question du carburant
j'ai répondu mais sur le le la question
de au fond de comment on arrive à faire
en sorte qu'il y ait des jeunes qui qui
qui viennent s'installer dans métier
c'est pour ça que d'abord il faut qu'on
ait un discours aussi positif c'est-à
dire que on a connu des crises on va
arriver à les surmonter il y a un enjeu
principal qui est celui de la
préservation de la biodiversité et la
transition énergétique pour et bien
avoir cette souveraineté aussi de de nos
flottes et et moi je j'ai vraiment en
allant dans tous les lycées maritims on
a des jeunes qui ont envie s'installer
qui ont envie de faire des pêches qui
sont différentes de ce qui pouit être
pratiqué par leurs aînés mais qui ont
envie de faire qui on envie de
participer aussi et bien à à l'activité
économique de leur pays il y a plusieurs
leviers au-delà de ce que vous avez dit
sur la transition énergétique à juste
titre enfin au-delà de ce que vous avez
dit pardon sur la formation 1 il y a
bien évidemment des bateaux qui soient
plus moderne plus neu enfin c'està dire
rien que d'avoir quand vous sortez à la
mer une semaine ou voir 3 jours d'avoir
des espacces de convivialitéah c'est
évident que peut-être qu'il y a 20 30
ans c'était accepté ou acceptable
maintenant les jeunes ils ont le choix
entre plusieurs métiers ils vont vite de
choisir donc ça c'est un élément très
important sur la modernisation des
navires des navires moins bruillants et
des navires qui respectent beaucoup plus
fortement l'environnement ça c'est une
demande et c'est ce qu'on va faire avec
ce plan de transition énergétique de 450
millions d'euros deux sur les aides à
l'installation là c'est dans le cadre du
féempa donc ils sont à la main des
régions il y a des aides à
l'installation poss possible il a des
aides à l'installation possible donc il
y a des régions qui le font d'autres qui
commencent à le faire et c'est vrai que
peut-être que l'enjeu de l'installation
était moins vrai il y a 20 ans
maintenant c'est un enjeu principal et
donc on travaille bien évidemment avec
les régions pour essayer de bien
calibrer et tout ça pour faire en sorte
qu'il y ait aussi et bien cet
inconvénent ce cou de pouce ce coup de
pouce ce coup de pouce pardon pour nos
jeunes ensuite et c'est lié à la
question de Madame Olivier c'est la
question aussi et bien dans les OP ou
dans la répartition des quotas d'avoir
et bien au-delà des critères sociaux et
environnementaux des critères sur ben je
sais pas c'est l'âge mais en tout cas
faire en sorte que on puisse en en
attribuer à des plus jeunes c'est ce que
nous nous avons fait avec notamment dans
le cadre du PAI en disant qu'il faut et
bien que on puisse donner la possibilité
à des jeunes qui n'ont pas de côtin de
pouvoir s'installer et donc c'est ce que
nous faisons avec la réserve qui est
issue du plan d'accompagnement
individuel ce qui leur donne des
capacités de pêcher des capacités de
produire et puis c'est aussi les accom
accagn avec des aides privées c'est ce
que fait cm acgm avec ces 20 millions
d'euros qui viennent et bien faciliter
accompagner des projets novateurs des
projets qui vise à expérimenter des
choses et ce qu'on envie aussi de faire
nos jeunes c'est-à-dire de d'essayer de
de tester aussi des modèles de pêche des
types de pêche qui sont peut-être un peu
différent de leurs aînés donc il faut
leur rend les moyens et ce fon cmcgm
leur permettra de le faire et pour
répondre à votre dernière question sur
l'enjeu de la vous avez parler de la
filière oui c'est tout le jeu de du
contrat stratégique de filière qui vise
justement à ce que les acteurs en entrex
se parle créer des
mécanismes soit plus fort en tout cas
plus solidaire et et et moi je crois
vraiment que à un moment donné on
arrivera aussi à la question de la
contractualisation c'est-à-dire que si
on veut que des jeunes s'installent il
faut la plurannualité des quotas parce
que ça le la visibilité et il faut bah
des poissons qui sont achetés peut-être
pas simplement à la semaine mais sur
quelques mois quelques voire quelques
années comme ça peut faire dans d'autres
secteurs c'est ce qui permettra de
donner de la visibilité là aussi et
d'avoir des modèles économiques et c'est
pas un gros mot qui soit durable et sout
able pour nos jeunes donc la plurinalité
des quotas ça permettra aussi à nos
jeunes de s'installer plus facilement
madame Olivier j'y a répondu un peu mais
vous avez raison sur le fait que cet
article 17 fait partie de ce que nous
devons aussi mettre en œuvre alors l'un
des piliers de la politique commune des
pêches c'est les ce sont les
antériorités c'est ce qui donne de la
visibilité parce que sinon chaque année
on change complètement et et on pourrait
aboutir à l'inverse de ce que vous dites
c'estàd que quelqu'un qui qui a beaucoup
d'argent dit bah moi je prends tout
alors queavec les inérie ité celui qui
était un petit pêcheur et bien il peut
continuer à avoir des droits de pêche
après donc il faut regarder aussi quels
seront les conséquence de ce que vous
dénoncez pas mais que ce que vous
pointez du doigt à juste titre et donc
cet article 17 nous comptons bien aussi
le décliner c'est la raison pour
laquelle dans le cadre de la réserve de
côat qu'il y a dans à la suite du PI
nous allons le décliner cet article 17
et nous allons lancer très rapidement un
décret en Conseil d'État pour pouvoir le
décliner donc on va commencer avec ce
cota qui est un peu Lim liité pour voir
aussi quels sont les effets quelles sont
les conséquences mais il faut bien avoir
en tête que les les antériorités c'est
aussi un des piliers de la PCP pour
éviter d'avoir des nousonventrants qui
sont très capitalistiques qui ont
beaucoup de moyens et qui ramasseraient
tout euh ensuite sur la question du euh
vous m'aviez posé la question des
dauphins euh sur la question du plan de
lutte contre les captures accidentell de
cetacé donc le le décret a été mis à la
consultation je suis pas très étonné
qu'il ne satisfait pas totalement les
pêcheurs ou les ONG ça fait partie vous
voyez de de la discussion en tout cas
nous nous avions trois impératifs que
nous avons tenu un se conformer à la
volonté du Conseil d'État de d'avoir des
fermetures spaciotemporelles ce qui est
la première fois et c'est des fermetures
spaciottemporelles qui couvrent tout le
golfe de gazcoog tout le golf de gazcoog
ce qui est gigantesque c'est 75 % le
golfe de Gascogne de toute cette façade
là on est le seul pays au monde qui a de
telles fermures passant temporelle 1 2
c'était bien évidemment de pas avoir des
mesures qui font que la filière dans
toute la façade atlantique
s'effondre il y a des activités de pêche
qui doivent être maintenu et trois c'est
d'avoir des mécanismes qui permettent
d'améliorer notre connaissance de la
science parce que personne autour de
cette table ne sait dire pourquoi il y a
autant de defin qui se retrouve dans cet
endroit comment on peut faire en sorte
pour limiter les captures accidentelles
au mieux donc c'est pour ça qu'on va
tester des dispositifs avec les cam avec
les pinger c'est répulsif qu'on va
augmenter le nombre de navires qui sont
dans cette expérimentation et à la fin
de du travail que nous allons déployer
qui a un coût quand même pour la
collectivité et c'est bien normal ce
sera plus de 650 navires qui seront
impactés par cette fermeture
spaemporelle 650 donc quand j'entends
dire que rien ne correspond à ce que
demander le Conseil d'État il y a des
fermetures spatiauemporelles ça touche
plus de 600 navires et par contre on va
pouvoir améliorer la science la
connaissance les données sur ces sujets
et nous le faisons aussi en essayant de
donner de la visibilité aux
scientifiques aux pêcheurs aux
collectivités parce que derrière les
pêcheurs qui ne vont pas aller en mer il
y aura des impacts sur les criers sur
les territoires et vous le savez que un
emploi en mer égale quatre emplois à
terre donc ça nous l'avons bien
évidemment
aussi en tête et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons fait un décret
qui tient ce que souhaite le Conseil
d'État ce que souhaite l'Union
européenne met en en avant la science la
connaissance la recherche et
l'expériment et fait en sorte aussi de
pas que la filière s'effondre totalement
en ce qui concerne le règlement
contrôle le vacom oui je on participe
alors je sais pas quel niveau c'est en
tout cas moi je n'y ai pas participé
personnellement mais les équipes qui
participent bien évidemment dans tous
les travaux de manière générale de toute
manière il y a trois grands pays qui
participent sur des sujets là c'est
l'Espagne le Portugal avant l'Angleterre
mais plus plus maintenant et et et la
France mais je pourrais vous donner une
réponse très précise sur les réunions et
cetera si vous le souhaitez
euh euh euh en ce qui concerne le
règlement contrôle parce que oui c'était
en c'est passe en trilogue euh c'est
déjà passé en trilogue c'est c'est déjà
passé en au au vote
euh euh l'ambition qui est la notre
c'est du bon sens du pragmatisme c'est
que on on va vraiment être attentif à ce
que dans la déclinaison dans les
obligations qui seront demandées en
terme de caméra on soit vraiment
réaliste en terme de de période de mise
en œuvre parce que on peut pas faire ça
de du jour pour le lendemain et donc sur
le le règlement contrôle nous ce qu'on
veut c'est du bon sens du pragmatis et
partir du terrain et partir de la
réalité de ces navires qui peuvent pas
s'équiper du jour au lendemain et puis
en ce qui concerne la pêche illégale
merci beaucoup de mentionner aussi ce
sujet parce que c'est un sujet qui est
crucial parce que la surpêche et surtout
la pêche illégale et le premier facteur
de baisse de la ressource et de la
l'effondrement du stock d'un certain
nombre de de de de poisson et donc sur
ça depuis
2020 particulièrement et Annie
gerérardin avait commencé le travail et
je le remercie également nous avons et
le président de la République a fait de
ce sujet une priorité en terme de
stratégie maritime dans les G7 des deux
dernières années nous avons porté le
sujet et ça a porté ses fruits puisque
pour la première fois au G7 au Japon il
y a eu une mention spéciale sur le
l'enjeu de faire de la lutte contre la
pêche illégale et il les cite un enjeu
prioritaire de tous les pays du G7 et
donc j'organiserai à la suite de ce G7
une réunion ministérielle avec tous les
ministres de ce G7 pour mettre en œuvre
la décision politique de haut niveau qui
a été portée par les différents sèfs
d'État et gouvernement première chose
deuxème élément la France a
rejoint l'Alliance internationale contre
la pêche illégale je vous passe le le
titre en anglais c'est iouu c'est dire
qu' une alliance qui permet de de mettre
en commun C nombre de moyens des données
et qui vise et bien à à a accélérer
l'action collective sur le sujet ensuite
nous avons demandé à la Commission
européenne de pleinement se saisir de ce
sujet j'en ai parlé encore lundi avec le
commissaire sivitus il faut que l'Union
européenne utilise ses cartons jaunes et
ses cartons rouges vis-à-vis de
paystiers qui ne respectent pas leurs
obligations en matière de lutte contre
la pêche égale je vous donne l'exemple
de guyan parce que j suis allé il y a 4
mois 90 % des tortues Lutes ont été
massacré c'est le terme de le dire du
fait de la pêche illégale par des pays
que je ne citerai pas mais je cité le
c'est en tout cas par des pêcheurs
illégaux brésiliens et des pêcheurs
illégaux du Surinam on a des actions de
coopération de commerce et de
développement avec ces pays moi ce que
je demande c'est que à partir du moment
où il y a des activités illégales qui se
déroulent sur notre territoire par ces
pays-tiers il faut que l'Union
européenne prennent pleinement les
sanctions et joue sur d'autres leviers
aide commerce financement pour faire
reculer cette pêcheigale ça fonctionne
notamment vis-à-vis des pêcheuresgau
Brésiliens puisquil y a eu des actions
très fortes coup de point de la part de
la marine française pour éloigner les
pêcheurs illégaux brésiliens et donc du
Pacifique et vous avez évoqué un certain
nombre de pays en passant par les
Caraïbes et l'Ocan indien l'action de la
France elle est résolue et nous allons
mener des des actions de coopération
entre nos marines européennes et les
marines de ces payslin pour aussi et
bien renforcer la sécurité maritime et
renforcer la souveraineté de nos de nos
eaux et et surtout préserver aussi la
viabilité et la les ressources dans nos
pays donc ça à plusieurs niveaux au
niveau multilatéral G7 au niveau
européen on demande à ce que la
Commission européenne prenne ses
responsabilités et au niveau aussi
national en terme de coopération nous
menons une lutte acharnée et nous aurons
au cours de la prochaine année aussi
avoir un travail très fin à faire sur
les close miroir c'est ce que je vous
disais c'est-à-dire que il faut qu'on
arrive à mieux identifier quels sont les
produits qui viennent dans nos assiettes
qui pourraent être issus de pêche
illégale et je crois que Pierre
carliskin le député européen a fait un
premier rapport sur le sujet et donc il
faut qu'on on accélère le le le le
travail en en la matière parce que en
plus plus la pêche illégale en général
faite avec des conditions sociales et
d'emploi des
des de personnes de marins qui sont des
conditions dignes de l'esclavagisme donc
il a aussi un enjeu social auelà d'être
un enjeu de sécurité et d' un enjeu
environnemental merci non non non mais
c'est si c'est précis c'est
bien en TR trois questions
complémentaires maraidrac et se prépare
katiya pouropoli
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous avez évoqué dans vos
propos liminires le sujet des éoliennes
et vous avez évoqué aussi les mesures
compensatoires vis-à-vis du monde de la
pêche professionnelle je voulais vous
poser une question au sujet de la
biodiversité on sait que l'implantation
d'éolienne n'est pas neutre du tout pour
la biodiversité marine donc comment
conjuguez-vous quelle signification
donnez-vous à ces mesures compensatoires
comment doit-on les traduire se trouve
que je suis à la Commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable et le sujet des
éoliennes sur le volet environnemental
aussi interroge un certain nombre
d'acteurs et je sais que alors peut-être
que l'acceptabilité vis-à-vis du monde
de la pêche est aujourd'hui au beau fixe
mais il me semble que ce n'est pas tout
à fait le cas donc j'aurais souhaité
avoir votre avis vos réflexions en la
matière pour savoir si euh j'ai envie de
dire des mesures compensatoires en sonné
en monnaie sonnante et tribuchante
suffisent en réalité pour faire passer
un certain nombre d'inconvénients pour
notre biodiversité marine je vous
remercie madame apoursopoli madame
Girardin qui se prépare al monsieur le
ministre moi je vais essayer d'être
brève parce que excusez-moi d'abord je
suis arrivé quelques minutes en retard
eu parce qu'on est
submergé d'audition dans tous les sens
euh voilà moi monsieur le ministre je
voudrais vous interroger peut-être que
vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs en début de
propos ou pas et donc c'est pour ça que
je m'excuse d'être arrivé en retard et
de ne de ne pas avoir entendu les débuts
de vos propos on le sait aujourd'hui la
filière pêche elle elle subit hein ça a
été dit par plusieurs de nos collègues
depuis plusieurs années d'abord hein je
vais pas revenir sur les contraintes
administratives sur les quotas sur la
réglementation quand même qui est très
lourde notamment sur les les petits les
petits marins pêcheurs qui sont souvent
dans les mêmes réglementations que les
grands bateaux qui ont parfois plus de
70 marins mais bon voilà je pense qu'il
faudra quand même travailler à tout ça
parce que c'est quand même assez pourux
euh difficile alors euh je l'ai dit la
la filière elle subit depuis plusieurs
années brexit gra en guerre en Ukraine
covid avec une situation donc ils ont
ont du mal finalement à laquelle ils ont
du mal à à à faire face et donc le
président insiste souvent sur notre
souveraineté alimentaire et je pense
pour ma part que c'est aussi important
de s'assurer une souveraineté
alimentaire mais vous avez annoncé donc
cette aide au carburant parce que c'est
un gros souci quand même euh vous avez
annoncé suite aux mobilisations qui ont
eu lieu évidemment quand même il y a eu
quand même des mobilisation un peu dans
dans ce pays donc que l'aide serait
reportée du du 15 octobre au 4 décembre
soit c'est une bonne chose et puis
évidemment nous en sommes satisfaits
ceci dit je pense que les pêcheurs ne
peuvent pas quand même être
suspendus à chaque fois à on ajoute un
mois on ajoute 15 jours on ajoute non
mais ils ne peuvent pas dans le métier
qu'ils font difficile avec les
difficulté être suspendu aux décisions
du gouvernement qui décide finalement
d'ajouter un mois 2 mois 3 mois 15 jours
voilà alors je je je vous pose une
question monsieur le ministre est-ce que
vous pensez travailler à des solutions à
beaucoup plus long terme parce que il me
semble que c'est important
réfléchissez-vous notamment à une taxe
flottante qui pourrait limiter la hausse
des prix à la pompe je vous
remercie merci Madame Gérardin oui merci
monsieur le Président rapidement
monsieur le ministre merci d'être à nos
côtés sur l'ensemble de ces sujets que
vous avez abordé moi je vais pas vous
avez répondu à la plupart des des des
sujets je vais revenir sur la question
de l'outrem et et la lié à la question
de la recherche et des données
scientifiques que nous avons à la fois
sur l'outrem mais avec une inquiétude
également sur l'avenir d' fremè
rapidement premier sujet on a des
sorties de flotte aujourd'hui dans
l'exag
toujours trop nombreuses on va le
trouver mais elles sont là euh j'ai
toujours pensé qu'il fallait qu'on
arrive à croiser ses sorties de flotte
avec les besoins des territoires
d'outrem bien entendu en rendant ses
navires bien plus sobre et et et en les
remettant aux normes si c'était possible
dans un monde où on parle de
développement durable dans un monde où
on parle effectivement de de de
d'économie raisonnable de cycle
raisonnable je crois qu'il faut vraiment
qu'on arrive à porter ça au niveau
européen on avait tellement d'urgence
qu'on l'a jamais porté et et et moi ça
m'affolle de voir des bateaux détruits
euh ça alors qu'à côté on cherche des
financement on nous annonce de 30 à
40000 € c'est compliqué euh et je crois
que le problème n'est pas que là euh on
estime que c'est pas assez mais en même
temps on détruit des bateaux à côté on
n'est pas dans les mêmes zones l'Europe
devrait pouvoir accepter qu'on y
travaille je crois qu'il y a une mission
particulière à faire là-dessus et et
quelque chose à porter pour les
prochaines élections européennes puisque
les changements vont pas se faire
immédiatement là ça c'était la petite
alerte sur la question des rupes et
notamment des aides effectivement à
l'investissement c'est très lié à notre
connaissance des de ces zones maritimes
et des données que nous avons euh
insuffisante jusqu'à aujourd'hui euh
très lié aussi à nos organismes
scientifiques qui n'ont pas
obligatoirement les moyens de les mener
ces études euh il y a ce lien là
qu'onarrive pas à faire où on se fait
renvoyer d'un côté par l'Europe parce
qu'on a pas toutes les données et puis
de l'autre côté ou
ifemè on va pas dire que sous l'eau
parce que c'est peut-être une partie de
son métier mais mais mais en vrai avec
des grosses inquiétude sur sur ces
sujets pour moi j'aimerais effectivement
qu'on puisse travailler sur cette
question d'ifreem et et que le ministère
de la mer et est davantage de capacité à
agir là aussi sur les programmes
d'ifremè est ce qu'ils peuvent mettre
mettre en place et puis une dernière
chose est-ce que il y a un
accompagnement des pêcheurs puisque
l'urope va nous renvoyer très très vite
quand on aura peut-être solutionné les
différentes questions qui se posent pour
l'aide à l'investissement dans les
territoires ultramarins pour
l'acquisition de navir est-ce qu'on a
travaillé sur la purement des dettes des
entreprises d'outremè parce que si on le
fait pas et ben au moment quand on aura
tout mis en place on se rendra compte
comme pour les mesures covid comme pour
toutes les autres mesures que ces
pêcheurs ne sont pas au rendez-vous de
ce qu'attend l'Europe et et on a ce
partenariat là à mettre en place avec le
ministère des outrmè bien entendu c'est
très compliqué hein on avait donné des
missions au TPG sur chaque territoire
très clairement nos deux ministères
ensemble outre mare et maire à l'époque
je crois qu'il y a plus personne qui
suit
merci très clair merci beaucoup alors
madame Sidrac de pardon je prie bien
voir Monsieur de
Sidrac sur l'enjeu de de de Lon lien et
de la biodiversité je pense que vous
avez parfaitement posé le le débat
d'abord nous nous finançons un
observatoire de l'éolien en mer pour
justement commencer à voir quels sont
les impacts les effets parce que la
réalité c'est que personne ne sait
exactement mesurer parfaitement les
impacts parce que ça dépend vraiment
voilà des
zones oui oui oui immédi ça c'est un un
impact visible mais je veux dire sur la
biodiversité parce que la biodiversité
parfois il peut y avoir des effets
ressifs parfois il peut y avoir des des
effets de report bref donc on va déjà
financer la connaissance la recherche la
science pour être en capacité et moi je
le dis puisque je viens d'un territoire
où il y a eu un parc éolienne au large
de la baie de saint-briux où il y a de
nombreux pêcheurs à la coquille et qui
sont très soucieux de la préservation de
cette ressource là et donc il faut qu'on
soit très précautionneux moi j'ai j'ai
j'ai dès le début d l'année dernière on
a fait en sorte que notamment olerond ne
se situe pas dans un parc naturel marin
pas dans le cœur du parc naturel marin
parce que en effet même si on a une
ambition de souveraineté énergétique il
faut faire très attention à la question
de la préservation de la biodiversité
parce que sinon ce serait des défire
d'un côté ce qu'on essaie de faire d'un
d'un autre mais en même temps si on n
pas une souveraineté énergétique si on n
acccélère pas sur les énergies
renouvelables la hausse de la
température va avoir un impact sur la
biodiversité donc il faut faire les deux
en même temps et avec cette ce qu'on
appelle le triptique éviter c'est ce
qu'on a fait au parc d'Oléron on l'a pas
mis dans le parc naturel marin réduire
quand on peut réduire les les impacts au
maximum et comme quand vous construisez
une autoroute comme quand vous
construisez une maison comme quand vous
construisez hôpital il y aura toujours
des impacts quand on fait ce type
d'activité donc c'est réduire et puis
compenser quand ce n'est pas possible
c'est-à-dire soit reconstituer soit
renaturé bref il y a tout un tas de
compensations qui sont possibles dans le
cadre de cette mise en œuvre des éol mer
donc éviter réduire compenser c'est au
fond la stratégie qui doit nous guider
qui guide aussi ce que l'on fait sur des
infrastructures à terre ensuite moi je
crois que l'enjeu qui est vraiment de
devant nous c'est d'arriver à à bien
objec
et c'est là où on a besoin de cette
observatoire c'est là où on va
travailler notamment avec avec la LPO la
lig de protection des oiseaux sur un
programme qui s'appelle migratlan pour
aussi réfléchir au couloir de migration
de des des oiseaux et donc une fois
qu'on aura tout ça je crois qu'on sera
en capacité d'avoir des éléments de
Constance ou en tout cas qui sont qui se
retrouvent un peu partout et puis
d'autres des éléments plus précis qui
nous permettront de précisément mettre
les parcs pour éviter réduire et et
français mais c'est évident c'est
évident que comme dans toute activité il
il pourrait y avoir des des impacts sur
la biodiversité mais l'enjeu de la
souveraineté énergétique et du
développement des énergies renouvelables
est aussi un enjeu qui est important et
prioritaire eu ensuite madame a pours
polii en ce qui concerne les les les Aes
carburants mais enfin moi je vous avez
parfaitement raison enfin vous le dites
mieux que moi les pêcheurs ne peut pas
être suspendu tous les 4 mois à la
question des AES carburants c'est la
raison pour laquelle à la fois ça c'est
du plus long terme il faut avoir une
transition énergétique de la flotte pour
ne pas dépendre des du du carburant et
donc de réduire notre dépendance à
quelque chose que nous ne produisons pas
et donc on sera toujours dépendant de la
volatilité des marchés de la décision de
Monsieur Poutine de Mohamed Ben Salman
et donc ça c'est pas possible et donc ça
c'est l'enjeu de la transition
énergétique la réduction aux énergies
fossiles et le deuxième c'est d'avoir au
sein de la filière aussi des mécanisme
qui permett de se couvrir sur le
carburant c'est-à-dire que vous dites
dans 6 mois j'achèterai le carburant à
tel prix parce que ça participe à 80 %
voire 70 % mon coûpt de production donc
on peut pas être simplement dépendant du
marché du carburant la semaine d'après
ou de semaines d'après donc c'est pour
ça qu'il faut ces mécanismes de
solidarité que ce soit avec l'engagement
de volontaire de Total ou avec des
répercussions du cût du carburant à un
moment donné sur les maillons de la
chaîne bref faire en sorte qu'on
internalise cette contrainte du
carburant au sein de la filière parce
que je partage complètement on peut pas
simplement être dépendant de ce que va
décider la Commission européenne sur de
carburant et je terminerai sur la
question de la taxe flottante il n'y a
pas de taxe sur le carburant maritime
donc l'enjeu n'est pas là il y a pas de
taxes madame Girardin madame la ministre
moi je partage complètement sur la
sortie de flotte et le fait de pouvoir
avoir ses navires qui soit réutilisé
ailleurs bon on na pas réussi à le faire
moi quand je suis arrivé aussi c'était
trop tard parce qu'il fallait décaisser
les financements mais je pense qu'il
faut qu'on ait une vraie réflexion sur
le sujet alors moi mon mon espoir c'est
qu'il n'y ait plus de sortie de flotte
massive mais il faut toujours se
préparer et donc en anticiper donc je
pense qu'il faut qu'on ait des
dispositifs qui évitent de se retrouver
avec des navires qui peuvent fonctionner
avec des réparations qui partent
totalement à la casse en ce qui concerne
au fond l'enjeu de la connaissance de la
science dans les rupes vous avez
parfaitement raison et donc on est en
train vraiment de travailler de
retravailler le contrat d'objectif et de
performance de l'ifremè pour faire en
sorte que certes c'est bien évidemment
la science mais c'est aussi un appui
technique l'ifreemè Nau technique
notamment à la modernisation à la
décarbonation à la transformation
évolution des techniques de pêche et
donc moi ce que j'ai demandé à Monsieur
Houlier c'est de retravailler bien
évidemment à la demande de la Premier
ministre ce COP pour que l'aspect
aide à la pêche l'aspect appui technique
et la décision soit beaucoup plus
important parce que il faut qu'on ait
cet outil qui est précieux pour mieux
déterminer stock la connaissance vous
savez que c'est pas un sujet facile mais
en tout cas on ira jusqu'au bout sur ce
sujet et en ce qui concerne la purement
vous avez là aussi
raison
on l'a fait dans le cadre de de du plan
clord d'écon et ça fonctionne et on voit
qu'on a des progressivement des
régularisations
dans par les pêcheurs ultramarins et
donc je CIS qu'il faut le faire avec bon
sens pragmatisme et en prenant le temps
nécessaire pour ne déstabiliser personne
je vous
remercie voilà nous allons nous
retrouver ouais je pense que N nos
collègues ont ont quitté la séance au
fur et à mesure pour monter voilà merci
puis bon à la prochaine puisque c'est un
rendez-vous
habituelp